what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so on the whole I usually try to
keep speculation videos to a minimum my
channel largely focuses on coming books
I just kind of talk about comics talk
about how they you know why they're
important and the history of them and so
on and so forth and what's going on at
the time and you know that kind of thing
for the most part speculation videos are
usually something that I leave to like
emergency awesome
for example Charlie's really really good
at that kind of stuff and it's really
informative and fun to watch his videos
when it comes to you know shows movies
things like that but I was thinking
about the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I was thinking about what
direction things are going to go in
following really the events of infinity
war and the second movie which I'm going
to call Infinity Gauntlet those are the
guys who don't know so far or at least
by the time the second infinity war
movie cabins concluding phase 3 that
means we will have had 20 movies so far
that I'll just tell one giant cohesive
story phase one was Iron Man Incredible
Hulk Iron Man 2 Thor Captain America one
and then it concluded with the Avengers
phase two was fire Man 3 Thor 2 Captain
America two guardians of the galaxy the
first one and then it had a vendor's age
of Ultron and it ended with ant-man
phase 3 was Captain America Civil War
Doctor Strange guardians to spider-man
homecoming that leads us to right now
which going into the future is Thor
Ragnarok then black panther and Dan
infinity war presumably Infinity
Gauntlet after that
now when guardians of the galaxy vol 2
we were basically given Adam warlock and
the funny thing about this is that with
the character of Adam warlock the idea
here was that he was just teased I mean
we'd simply had this you know sovereign
race which was just this really
technologically advanced race who
created Adam warlock to be their perfect
beam those are guys who were not
familiar with with Adam he's basically
Marvel space Jesus that's really what he
is he's their Messiah he wasn't
originally that way originally he was
just a guy who was created by this group
called the enclave who were enemies of
the Fantastic Four
and the idea was of the enclave wanted
to basically take over the world and use
technology in order to do it and still
this kind of technologically perfect
world that was governed and run
explicitly by Ben the Fantastic Four
ended up finding the the enclave Adam
warlock appeared battle the Fantastic
Four for a while took off battled for
and then took off into space and that
was really about it his really big claim
to fame came during like a story called
counter-earth was a handful of stories
but that was one of the most notable
ones he faced off against the High
Evolutionary this guy that
super-smart with genetics basically
evolves his own physiology giving
himself virtually godlike powers uh
which eventually led to Adam warlock
being crucified and then being
resurrected but during that whole thing
he got the soul stone so that's really
where that whole concept with his
character comes from going into the
1990s Adam warlock got his biggest claim
to fame as part of Infinity Gauntlet
which we'll talk about that here in a
minute but I would surmise that Adam
warlock as we know is going to appear in
going into the galaxy 3 the question is
in what capacity will he exist and what
role will he play my argument is this
Adam warlock will appear in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 I also think Adam
warlock is going to appear in the
Infinity Gauntlet film and here's the
reason why when it comes to the Marvel
Comics to the Infinity Gauntlet story
Adam warlock was a rallying point alum
warlock was the guy who basically
organized the superheroes attempt to
defeat Thanos now of course it didn't
work he wrecked the absolute hell out of
them because he basically was wielding
the power of the universe I mean was
crazy you know how powerful he was but
Adam warlock was the rallying force he
was the guy that was behind the line
saying you do this you do that he
organized all the cosmic entities
different things like that
now if the sovereign race in guardians
of the galaxy - were the ones who
created Adam warlock and the sovereign
race are considered to be the most
advanced race in the Marvel Universe
against the mortal cinematic universe it
stands to reason the sovereign know
everything about everything now if they
are an extremely knowledgeable group of
people then they're most likely governed
by logic as opposed to emotion and that
was the indication that was given to us
in the movie I mean we saw instances
where you sure would get angry she'd get
upset various members would be very
irritated with others different things
like that but all indications are given
to us they are just a highly advanced
race based more on logic and reason
science different things like that then
like religious concepts and so the idea
here is in my mind Adam warlock will
emerge in Infinity Gauntlet Adam warlock
may initially fight some of the
superheroes who knows but Adam warlock
being governed by reason as the perfect
being created by the sovereign would
look around and say okay the universe is
in jeopardy the only other thing that I
can think about is that at the time Adam
warlock has released the original
intention of Aisha is to basically
defeat the guardians of the galaxy or
something along those lines but with
fans reeling the Infinity stones with
Thanos basically pushing the universe
edge of extinction maybe he blinked out
half the life in existence and the
sudden shock of energy waste Adam
warlock of you know out of his cocoon
any number of things could happen Adam
warlock will emerge he will observe the
scenario and say okay the universe is in
danger
somebody needs to rally the superheroes
now what this will do is it'll lead to
probably his encounter with like vision
and vision will inevitably say hey this
guy's legit this guy's cool or maybe
Adam warlock will be able to pick up the
hammer fork and prove his worth that
seems to be the method that Moore was
using at the moment if somebody's unsure
whether her characters are a good guy or
a bad guy we'll see if they can lift a
hammer they can pick up the hammer
they're worthy so they're not all that
bad I mean we found that out with vision
age of Ultron Adam warlock emerging
means that he would basically be the
rallying point he would look at Doctor
Strange and much like the comics you
would say okay Doctor Strange you are
going to be the ferryman you're going to
be the guy who's going to create portals
that are going to be able to you know
allow superheroes to teleport between
earth all the way over to wherever it is
that Thanos is that during the Infinity
Gauntlet film you're going to be the one
casting the spell so superheroes can
breathe in space you're going to be
doing all that stuff you're going to be
the supporting character he's also going
to look at like Captain America and say
you are a genius when it comes to like
field tactics and combat and so on and
so forth you're going to be the guy
who's going to be leading the charge on
the front lines when you're facing off
against and I'm going to be the guy
who's going to be back here watching it
all and telling you what you need to do
and how you need to change tactics and
so on and so forth I'm going to be the
mastermind behind the whole thing and
that stands to reason because again if
the sovereign or this genius level race
that have basically imbued Adam warlock
with knowledge on everything that's ever
happened in existence did it make sense
that he would say I'm the best person to
go to in order to decide what direction
we should take because I'm not governed
by fear or anger or anything like that
now following this the story would
likely end in the defeat of Spanos let
me keep in mind the infinity war film
the first film it's probably just going
to be fan o's showing up on earth with
the intention of taking the mind stone
away from vision it's only going to be
the last stone he needs to get and that
that will probably just be the entire
basis of the conflict everything that
we'll see an infinity war will likely be
Thanos using his powers - the mind stone
when the mind stones put with the
Infinity Gauntlet that's when the true
power is unlocked and that's when it's
like oh my god we weren't even really
fighting him at full power that's when
things are going to pop off so that will
really just be infinity war but with
infinity go
what will likely happen is the the film
will probably follow the comic in a
sense that Thanos will just grow hubris
and you know arrogant because he's like
I had absolute power he'll make himself
one with the universe and in this moment
of being stupid effectively nebula will
grab the Infinity Gauntlet and she'll be
the one with absolute power Thanos will
have to work alongside the earth
superheroes in order to defeat nebula
Adam warlock will take the gauntlet and
he'll just be like let the conflict end
to me that's what I think will happen in
those films now following this the
question is what role will Adam warlock
play following the Infinity Gauntlet
story there was a story called infinity
war which is actually kind of ironic
here and the movies infinity Wars coming
first in the comics infinity war came
second the difference here is infinity
war in the comics was a totally
different story from what you're going
to see in the movies again the infinity
war movie will be Santos coming to earth
it'll basically be the comic book story
when Thanos showed up on earth looking
for the Cosmic Cube
that's basically what's going to happen
replaced Cosmic Cube with a mind stone
of the vision and there's infinity war
now what happened in the comics is that
following the events of Infinity
Gauntlet Adam warlock - the Infinity
Gauntlet and then was brought before the
Living Tribunal the judge of the
multiverse and the Living Tribunal
decreed that Thanos his goal was to
basically take the place of eternity the
most powerful being in the universe the
representation of the universe the
Living Tribunal said okay every universe
has its own eternity danos was just
taking the place of that one it's the
order of things those who were too weak
to maintain their roles will be cast
aside for those who were strong enough
to replace them that's just the way the
world works the weak make way for the
strong without a warlock it wasn't that
way Adam warlock was governed by reason
and logic but Adam more like didn't know
is he actually purged his evil and good
personas and so he was basically just
this neutral being but Adam warlock
looked to wield the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet alongside eternity
which basically would have made this
imbalance of power there can only be one
absolute powerful being in the universe
at any one particular point in time and
so because of this Adam warlock was
instructed by the Living Tribunal to
disperse the Infinity stones what also
ended up happening is a Living Tribunal
had a be plan living tribunal said okay
I am the second most powerful being in
all of existence I judge the multiverse
I'm more powerful than the Infinity
Gauntlet and so what a living tribunal
did is basically make it so that even if
Adam warlock went back to earth and
tried to use the Infinity Gauntlet
nothing would happen the stones would
never work in unison again and so
because of this Adam warlock formed what
was called the infinity watch now the
infinity watch was basically a group of
people who were all given Infinity
stones and they were basically told to
safeguard those stones they were a loose
net team for the most part they fought
side by side and various conflicts
things like that but the overarching
idea was that they could disband it
could go off and do their own thing have
their own stories and presumably their
stories would feature them using
whatever stone they had now the idea was
that Thanos was one of the people who
got an infinity stone he actually got
the reality stone but moondragon the
daughter of Drax a destroyer was a
member of the infinity watch hit the
troll who's a character that we haven't
seen yet in the movies was a member of
the infinity watch he actually shoved
his in his rear end I think that's it's
really kind of messed up but that's
basically the role that Adam warlock
played
he was the focal point of the infinity
watch he led this team of people whose
goal was to safeguard the Infinity
stones now the reason why this happened
was because in the comics marvel wanted
to put the Infinity stones on the
backburner they didn't want to get rid
of them forever because they were like
hey look the Infinity Gauntlet is this
wildly powerful story people love seeing
super opie characters being faced off
against by what's you know this
hodgepodge group of heroes who are just
doing the best they can despite getting
absolutely wrecked we want to make sure
we can use the Infinity stones later the
Marvel Cinematic Universe seems to be
taking the exact same approach at least
I imagine they would I doubt they would
go that Jonathan Hickman Avengers New
Avengers route what Captain America gets
the Infinity Gauntlet tries to use it
the stones explode and they all
basically disappear and they're gone
forever the reason behind that as a
whole of the kettle of beans and that'll
be part of our whole Marvel cosmology
thing but that seems to be the direction
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
going in and that's the direction I see
Adam warlock going in I see Adam warlock
debuting in the Infinity Gauntlet film I
see Adam warlock being the guy that
Corral's all the superheroes together at
least what's left of them
and has them face-off against Thanos as
best they can I see Adam warlock being
the one to bring the conflict to an end
and I see Adam warlock being the one who
forms the infinity watch it's part of
phase four and you could even call it
that
guardians of the galaxy 3 infinity watch
it makes sense to me you know if they
end up going out and doing that thing
but I'm kind of curious about where you
guys you know stand on this what are
your thoughts you guys agreed you guys
disagree I'd love to know what your all
thoughts are it'd be interesting you
know to see what what you guys think
about this kind of thing because
everybody has their own theories on what
role
Adam warlock will play information right
now is scant so it could be in six
months this video is totally irrelevant
I have no idea that people are just like
nope everything is wrong I have no idea
but if you guys are new here to Commons
explain you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
dug this make sure you drop a light and
yeah leave a comment down below let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you all later peace
you